[Music]
there is a definite connection between
the physical laws of inertia right a
body in motion tends to stay in motion
and the psychological components of
inertia it's like when we become
sedentary it's very difficult to begin
moving again right and to become
motivated once more and it's not just
emotional it's also physiological
depression and feeling sedentary and
feeling down and engaging once again in
being hopeful because essentially that's
what motivation does require can become
a bit like a spiderweb in the six keys
one of the major pathways we need to
travel down is comprehending the
connection between the state of our mind
and how it very tangibly affects our
bodies when you look at something like
depression or sadness or tragedy that
kind of emotional stress we see that it
literally changes our brain it shrinks
the size of our amygdala our hippocampus
it shifts the ratios between gray matter
and white matter it changes our brain
chemistry and what all of these
physiological changes do is essentially
gear us to be more impulsive less
emotional regulation more prone and
depression and these thoughts then of
course lead to our behaviors right which
dictate the outcome of our reality so as
I mentioned it's it's a bit of a black
hole so to speak so how do we turn it
around and it has to be something in my
opinion that is fought on a myriad of
fronts first and foremost we need to
establish a why right so we're gonna
look at the actual psychology of
motivation and I believe it was
Nietzsche who said if you have a why to
live for you can tolerate the how
because anything worth having be it a
healthy marriage a thriving career a
healthy body is going to require work
and sacrifice
but work with purpose is passion work
without purpose is punishing and a lot
of us already feel very punished by the
rigors of our daily lives so forming a
very concrete goal not just health right
what does that even mean how do you
emotionally connect to being healthy
somebody says oh well you know don't
have that pizza tonight and don't watch
how to make a murderer season two and
you'll be healthy like that's not sexy
however if it was hey you know what give
me 20 minutes
in your living room with a quick
exercise routine and get the sauce on
the X Y or Z meal you just ordered on
the side forego the soda get water
instead and you're gonna fit into those
skinny jeans have sex with the lights on
with confidence although I think that's
greatly overrated it's light at least
twelve hours out of your day so why not
open up your options right I mean walk
your daughter down the aisle will look
good in your wedding dress or meet your
great-great-grandchildren watch humans
land on Mars I don't care what your
reason is it doesn't matter how profound
it is it doesn't matter how superficial
it is but it has to move you and you
have to care because that's what makes
that work in order to achieve it more
manageable and turns it into passion
versus punishment at the same time how
do we make this concept neuroplasticity
work for us right instead of against us
how do we change our brain chemistry in
the shape and size of various parts of
our brain so that we are more prone to
positivity and hopefulness as opposed to
nihilism well things like meditation
these mind-body interventions and for
the longest time I was like oh I live in
LA like I can't hear this one more time
you know what's gonna stress me out
wasting five minutes chanting in my car
on my lunch hour when I have stuff to do
but the evidence is overwhelming and we
see that five minutes even of meditation
I don't care when you get it in if it's
in the morning if it's at night if it's
in your lunch hour even if you suck at
it download an app be consistent with it
and over time we see that it helps to
shift
the physiology of our brain so we are
more geared towards happiness purpose
and meaning and in fact when we look at
it holistically in conjunction with that
ball getting rolling right so now maybe
you've got just enough motivation to
take that first step and you're moving
so the first step at the gym the first
one's always the hardest because now
that body in motion stays in motion now
you're motivated to a certain extent
you're starting to see results the fears
and concerns with breaking out of that
comfort zone have abated because you
already went and you did it maybe you're
uncomfortable at the gym you dealt with
feeling uncomfortable the gym you
survived it you're ready to go back
tomorrow the world's not gonna end
you're eating a little bit healthier and
all of those micronutrients aren't
gearing your brain chemistry for the
better and not the worse so each and
every step in the right direction is
what begets more success so it's a
holistic and accumulative approach
that's going to yield those positive
results in then of course once you're
emotionally and physically in motion
it's much easier to stay in motion
[Music]